some yardage a park would teach you how
to drink soju all my bills pay so he
buddy get rid of this old
so Jew is the traditional drink of Korea
everybody drinks it you can drink it
with your your buddies or you can drink
it with someone that's older than you or
is it kind of fits for any occasion so
what you do before you open the bottle
is you whip it around turn it around
hit it with your elbow for the sound
what it looks and then you would crack
it open
and what some people do is they hit it
like that just so all the stuff on the
top and all the bad stuff comes out and
what you could do with the cap and some
people like to play a game with it so
you twist it around like this and then
you take turns for Flickinger whoever
flicks off this little tail right here
they have to drink the soldier if you're
pouring for someone that's elder than
you you want to blow it two hands to
show respect looks like this it's your
friend just warning
it's your comfortable clothes the same
thing when you're receiving it for
someone Eldon two hands HMDA it's your
friend who's one hand like this and if
it's someone elder you drink you want a
drink with your back turned so that they
don't see you drink the sign of respect
so this how you cheers come bear I just
talked to her to drink soju jay Park
only Asian to be sign of the Roc Nation
there see much more yeah it was good
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so described here that was my
part